citizens the reject Nation it's time for Loki
episode four of season 2 don't expect five and
six to get up this early I'm telling you that
much guys so just be grateful for Now ladies
and gentlemen first things first I want to say
thank you to all watch that interview that Koy
did With Yuri lenthal for Spider-Man game was a
great one thank you for all the support there if
you haven't seen it go ahead watch it speaking
of coy coy how are you very excited to be here
that's what I love to hear John Haro I couldn't
be 15 times more excited than Coy is or aoris
uh ladies and gentlemen leave a like on this
video that' be very much appreciated subscribe
click the notification Bell get notified when
our reaction for the next episode is Loki is
up on the chat watch with copy Avail over
page Reaction watch included this intro is
short green means PR there you are
the TVA is in danger I bet we find
out this episode he pruned himself think so
Theory different tune every Marvel studios's
logo nice Multiverse lost him
in the circuits of time dter
timelines color me intrigued nice
open right where we left off he wasn't always
alone there's something you have
to see you were with him are love
tape little diarama so it's almost ready oh my
God a Utopia at the end of time for us for all
time always always this is for the recording
great call R RN Slayer you are Marvel you are
quite a Marvel I would be proud to lead with you
but not as my partner you made a difference in
this war thank you for being on my team the TVA
awaits our commands our commands shall we go I'll
catch up oh how is he able to wipe memories
in a long road see you soon it's crazy Miss
minutes has all the information is it every time
anything she is aware of pull up protocol 42 is
it time arase her memories how did he do that
erase all their memories if you say so Order
66 I'm sorry regret it's the guy restarts
the video game every time he falls down
high score I helped win you didn't just help it
was you who commanded the army so he built this
little Tower and while he sat on his throne I
continued to do all the work to keep him there
no one would believe a woman could do this
guys come on the power Dynamic what are you
proposing that we don't need him maybe we never
did M no oh miss minutes destroy the patriarchy
Miss scorn minute lover man I've been getting
theories right the most obvious theories I've
been getting right and they have been correct
because you just need to read like one comment
tie some [__] together Source material
perhaps relevant oh boy welcome that's
what a great shot he's lighing right in front of
him what he could be what he is what he's been
wow the weight of that seeing
what you built and then literally
you any of this look familiar Bud
you're
hello stop what do you want with me temporal
Aura come with us and we'll show you that
didn't sound as reassuring as you hoped it
would only imagine what Ren Slayer and Miss
Min have been saying about us but it's not true
unless I said something good I'm from Chicago I
don't trust anyone oh it's a party hello you
all want me Rona wants me the effervescent
clock lady monster thing yes that's your loom
and you're the only one who can help us fix
it great response so do is alive she's in holding
with the others we can't keep them there forever
what do you want to do you tell me I subtle o
Crush Zoom I know what we would have done in the
past pruned all of them there's a lot of shots
like somewhere what vois she is a general and
she wants to protect it at all costs that was her
Mission and it can be again if you can convince
her this a tall in order seem pretty committed
to the old way your words changed me there's
always like something bigger is watching yeah it
makes it really ominous and unnerving time itself
watches chocolate soup could we just take a take a
look trust me it's not that great later later man
you're here to solve one of many PRS then you're
free to wander around all you want just love how
quirky he is that'd be so hard to stay focused
Victor this is Casey and OB let's see if Obi has
any familiarity OB that's right he admires Ora
Boris from the book you wrote the TVA handbook
but I learned everything I know from a brilliant
19th century inventor in then Victor timley wow
an Ora Boris of learnis that's a brilliant
this moment what did you say your name was
Victor your work is based on his work and his
work is based on your work exactly which came
first it's like a snake eating and don't tail yep
inscribe my my handbook only if you inscribe mine
so many people learning this word is it's the
first time he's ever got a fan club at all these
years there's a model I mocked up with the loom
forgive the shy and slap work it's not too scale
I only got one coat of paint on there it's okay
good honestly embarrassed that Victor is here to
see it no SC it's simple one of us will have to
take our throughput multiplier it will scale the
lom's capacity to manage the backlog of branches
that was created when I'm keeping up I'm keeping
up someone killed he who remains first person
to acknowledge it and ruined my life finally
much more Temple radiation out here than there
was when you went out there Ms yeah so much more
more yes you're going to get skinned again okay
well I mean Loki's really going to have to Huff
it then right why it why is it only me having
to HFF it it's your show that's why you're also
God clearly this isn't me just because it isn't
you is necessar me I your [__] to Victor T it
doesn't matter who it is just needs to be super
fast okay great so what we waiting for let's do
this step in Victor yeah working magic it's only
theoretical because our throughput multiplier does
not yet work why doesn't work wait I don't know
I feel like we're watching the rise of a villain
right now 100% he's about to do something out
pieces your multipliers do put capabilities
how does he take advantage of this I had the same
problem with my loom until I made this my priced
possession a protal typ wa does It remix figure
inating them if that would even work would take
a long time a long time always if anyone can
it's you and me oh no okay come on dude I so
on Sylvia's side about everything the level of
distrust I'm like way with let's have a little
pie while we wait have a little pie so you must
have some idea of what's Happening everything is
turning to [__] o and you want to leave it to
them while we go and have some pie great idea M
hey Sylvie what are you going to do clocks don't
tick at the TVA do they H you found out you're a
variant and you haven't even looked have you
it's interesting lighting keeps coming back
to this once he knows it's real it's real to
him doesn't matter if a you disappear because
you've never bothered to look if one of them
was yours who cares if a few just disappear
keeps from remove that smart dis associate Joy
pie I like that they lit him like angelically
and her are like evil but she's right about how
he's absolving himself by ignoring or maybe the
lighting is a clue oh listen up we don't have any
weapons lead the revolution my friend I think if
we put our heads together and if we just try to
figure this out we can get out of this room and
we can get back to our lives what is this
going to be I believe it was Galileo or or
Winston Church it seemed like you gave up when
you sold out our plan I didn't know you knew
that I earned my life I auditioned an audition
when so many so much money on head shot classes
don't you think you earned your life no oh she
regrets I mean they're all lost all of their
belief system and identity has just been shattered
I don't want any of this certainly don't want to
be talking to you but I know you care about the
TVA and I know you want to protect it that's the
only reason I'm here you had good intentions if
we have to fight to defend this place can we trust
you you're serious they do want the same thing at
the end of the day I care about this place these
people I'm just going to spend the rest of the
reaction like this banged up bed up Y what if
they don't go for it go and help mobas keep an
eye on timely this feels more like the pace and
the tone of the first episode yeah I'm really
enjoying it I do wish we had a little bit more
time with docs before we started getting all
this stuff though agre I had a little bit more
emotional investment in some of this [__] with
her the plot is good but uh yeah connection yeah
the whole like is there an episode missing here
didn't plan on coming to Pand hey McDonald's got
apple pies did they prune that timeline who's
the Pand timeline I would like to visit Pand
this is All That Remains of the Pand timeland P
who remains not the pies no for all pie always
he's just trying to see in the dark like the rest
of us o good line I asked for your help and you
walked away just so we're clear no I didn't
I'm here aren't I again is he couldn't kill
him yeah couldn't kill him time he just looked
so scared he who remains wasn't scared I love
how these two are in their own weird Indie Melo
drama some years ago my brother was banished from
Asgard and sent to Earth I remember that and
when he came back he was different I remember
that another I thought it was weakness you
spared timely's life and because of that the
TVA and those timelines Will Survive there's a
chance putting a lot of faith in those three B
what else do we have don't forget docs she's
part of the TVA all those dead branches those
dead people they're individuals though you know
what about those branches that are still living
that's because of Mobius and B15 and those guys
back there OB and Casey who are part of the TV it
would just be easier to burn this place down
and start from scratch raising things to the
ground is easy yeah trying to fix what's broken
is hard him showing his Thor change in a direct
way hope is hard so timely con for the TVA we
hope that the TVA turns into something good oh
no we hope that timely doesn't turn into he who
remains or someone worse that's a lot of hoping
Loki I mean all you got is Hope at the end of the
day bring him behind the curtain just send him
home maybe that's a good thing watch him protect
him interfere for good heard that one before yeah
both the perspectives are so fair you can't
give people Free Will and then just walk away
it's up to us to protect them whatever we do we're
playing God Gods I mean that's the that's the job
the ironic part that they have be become playing
Gods how ironic you are you are the gods Gods
yeah oh I love it because you
it can lead down a dark path
yeah but like there's a lot there's big
cautionary tail here what a great debate
and a beautiful shot great debate going
into the darkness I don't trust B5 so I
oh boy oh no good holy [__] oh goody that there
expected there's B15 she's setting in place her
plan to control the TVA we work together we can
stop her protect this place oh clever to protect
is yourself raona an already assembled Army and
you at a general General Like Pat over here I
know I'm working on myself I I've been gone mere
days and this place is hours away from becoming a
crater Rafa standing in the middle waiting to
see what side he takes driven into the ground
by two variants is that what you want you're all
variants anyone who joins me and helps me restore
stability to the TVA will have a life on the
timeline if they want it damn this is like some
Game of Thrones [__] now man y damn choose your
side yeah I like that he's been holding that for
freedom but also like positioning and then as
soon as he's offered it's like the let go it's
very like symbolic of like this is how we escape
this great cat I thought you could see the bigger
picture
oh oh miss minutes holy [__] for the first
time I finally am seeing the bigger picture
o please stop you made a rather impressive
life for yourself on the timeline love aniac
X5 Bradley oh he's already decided he's just
trying to accept what he just decided to do
life in the timeline was that good huh you've
been called him Bradley W damn just him ug how
does it feel knowing that all of us here
would rather die than follow you out that
door wof oh my God Miss min looking gleeful
oh W I love it oh X5 oh like a cedral of
horror that could have been you a couple
episodes ago oh and he just endures I
wish we saw it yeah it's Disney plus
Max let's go X5 o Ren Slayer there's
just a puddle of your old co-workers
right there next to you he's like
uh Carl Orban from Ragnarok now
spectacular got a little alternator in
there what oh say about to discover coffee
courtesy of the hot cocoa machine hoto machine
yeah that wasn't in the TVA Hat book give that man
some cocoa about this hard cocoa machine could I
take a look this is a diversion something's about
to happen in that room he doesn't want to be in
there for and he waited for any excuse I mean
what did he to get out I think that room's not
going to be safe oh we're going to see the mush
let's see the mush come on see some steamy bones
uh-oh that was definit you're not going
to believe this they off themselves
oh you didn't say the magic word God
damn it I mean he created some type of
machine that was sh ravona in the last episode but
I want to be altruistic and just
he wants hot coco but I I don't
trust
what I don't speak I a featured
extra that would have cost more
guy was almost a day player the hell is
happening oh chocolate soup
yeah God damn it God damn
it at least his last moments were
good right on the line oh my God
this is crazy now we've got a villain
team up sorry you're not sorry at
all oh where's the
device oh I not how I expected things
to go Victor seems good did you download
unauthorized games again no I think this is
so intense man author games again this is
so intense oh oh he's getting Jurassic Park
too she's taking control of all the systems
that's why the T pads aren't working grab the
multiplier and let's get timely yeah take the
serious major nipple chills run it oh my
God I'm so tense here oh my God he turned
him into a puddle of cocoa this is where the
crime took place this is so suspenseful Tim
Le gone Miss minutes is back docs and her team
are dead oh man All Is Forgiven this is such a
good buildup what a cofy all roads led to this
in episode four I haven't had time to test it
but without timely it doesn't matter without
his Aura I can't open the blast do w r slay
doesn't want him she wants the TVA they still
here call is coming from inside the house said
sit now she's in front of the king
thank ruling God your boy both okay
oh jeez sit down sitting down sitting down
you're going to tell us where to find your
device oh man I don't want this to end if you
don't like what I have to tell you an X5 here
an incredibly painful way to kill you it's a
very small box I think you're going to like
what I have to say back to the showman back to
the presentation there is a machine that develops
hot cocoa and had a c they call it a dunino if
you find our Spirits would be lifted they will
discontinue it in 2022 and it'll upset one man
particularly his name is Coy he's watching this
show oh P 9000 over here wait we're going to go
to the open episode where she comes out the it's
going to be improved himself it's happening
we're going to or a Boris back to episode one
in the episode where they explained to Ora Boris
oh my God it's all in Ora Boris it's all circles
which means episode 5 is our first
new episode since we know what
happened brilliant brilliant brilliant
right back to where we started oh my God
I think we meet Kang in episode five
this is like some prisoner of baban
[__] gorgeous look at that access to access
oh hot wire that [__]
Tex just a manual elevator
override now who called the phone oh
yeah we probably that's moments away
we're about to find out still think
of Trinity this is so smart come on
oh my God he did prune himself he did I
know you called it man yes it's episode
one episode called it yeah and we're all
back as an Ora Boris absolutely called it
get him oh how strange cuz of course the
god of Mischief wouldn't trust himself
he's the god of Mischief oh my God Dam
you nailed that dude I didn't I thought
it' be an episode epod five thing I
thought it'd be the end before the
finale I love how he pieced it together yep
you just see him learning like oh I got to do
it there it is O there you are that's why she says
that and now he's the time stuck
the the the the time warping which
is why we're going to see that in
more episodes that we saw footage
from yep I promise you this will make
sense wow this is like some
aronowski [__] but who's
calling oh please don't cut please don't cut
is it Loki is it Kang I don't think they're
going to cut cut low great shot beautiful
the weight of the phone hello about time oh
it's I love how casual the reveal was that was
great I could take her offline if I reboot the
system yeah yeah yeah reboot the system yeah dude
security protocols will go down is Casey going to
go out there D oh Casey's going to sacrifice
himself cuz he's wholesome no I love Casey
that is getting worse that's not another
power surge let me investigate get out of
here miss minutes I can't I'm being locked
out oh taking me offline I'm losing my C
facility I need to tell you
I love you I need to you all
T his fries you'll never be him oh
right in front of him floppy disc
TVA is Victor going to be jealous
of Kang oh look like the eyes were
opening I mean that's a good thing
if he never becomes unless he wants
to what's that his villain what
if like that comic I recommended
what if his villain origin story
that's what I was thinking yeah
which is also an
oror yeah let get
spooky yeah puff yourself
up what do you say X5 fancy rematch no powers this
time [__] that was dope oh Wicked
oh because they're offline she could
use the powers yeah there's no
yeah no security there's no inh
inhibition because normally they can't
use powers in the TV what's going on you
Enchanted this is cozy what she's in
his she's in him never a second come
here come here what is going on here I didn't
think I'd see you again so soon she's in him
yeah yes yes which way where not bad
oh dude she's probably going to see
elith yep and then just let him go and now he
has to deal with ramifications come on hry right
here this way over here this is expertly crafted
episode it's so good first we need Mr timely's
Aura scans so we can get the blast doors open
I don't trust him something's about to go down
just put your head in the scanner is that safe
theoretically it's all right well his hairfit
do we need need a hair net or swimming cap
I do feel like he would trust OB because of
that reverence but I'm still worried about
what happens welcome he who remains you did
it he did stall I feel like I want to trust
Victor I mean he doesn't want to be the bad
guy I have to move fast who's it going to be
I'll do it sacrifice but case's already out
there oh case's up there oh is he okay okay
okay time to be brave good luck time to be
brave it's hard to be Brave Brave Little Toaster
it's even worse than when I was out there make
it I don't know he who remains wanted him to get
the hand [__] in the beginning yeah does this
radiation activate something if you're going
to get time Powers it's not it might just be
a path but also like the power of controlling
time I imagine time radiation would affect your
ability to control time oh yeah is he about to
get activated is this how Kang is born temporal
radiation
wow oh my
god wow oh my God Mom spaghetti wo
what do you even do what happened he's gone
what happened it's over what is he dead what
is it what did we do wrong I don't know what
happened I don't know oh the horrors I don't
know oh the Kings keep dying I'm sorry I
didn't trust you Victor yeah oh oh oh this
is oh Christ hell yes what is about to happen it
looks like film burning almost how many
billions of lives are imploding right
now how many incursions they might be being
transferred is this the end of the timeline
yeah no more Marvel Canon event it's over
that Kevin feige reboots coming sooner than
we thought it's great to go to the handheld oh
[__] godam it God what a shot to end on end
it it's Darkness the darkness of that oh my God
and Justin directed that one the first episode
and they directed the first that's why it felt
perfect you Geniuses damn that was an expertly
crafted episode I am exhausted I tired that was
ex that was that was expertly D Not only was their
mom spaghetti my PS are so that is that is one of
the best episodes of all of MCU television period
that stayed taught the whole way it also fixed
my issues with episodes two and some of three
it was so good it retroactively like got me there
wow you have no IDE like that was but you still
have you still have the ability to go to reject
naations shop.com and get yourself some teas to
support the channel nipple chills I got nipple
chills the space babies of the Galaxy this Loki
inspired Merch this other Marvel merch that we
got too and then this shirt right here and then
that shirt right there and then every single
one helps to support the channel in great ways
and man there's some Sinister credits playing
before us right this is ominous knew and that
monkey was terrifying oh yeah Monkey Shines
boy you get the had Victor timely there shot
I'm wondering if there's Easter eggs for future
stuff or like like references that we'll catch
because now we're back to the beginning of the
show because it's an Ora Boris and the death
of Victor I think brings about another Kang oh
it must cuz untethering him from all time I'm
I'm curious how that relates but also the idea
that he was a good Kang he stayed good and I
didn't trust him I love how much of a horror
show this is man like guy got spaghetti well
and on Loki I mean he who remains is obviously
dubious but like the kangs we've met directly
via Loki are like not overtly evil whereas you
know Quantum Mania is pretty clearcut I mean he
must have been I don't know if they me he was
killed then because they were all caught up
in that in that that final moment so they must
have been transferred somewhere there's no way
they just killed them but there is that Loki who
was pruned yeah the one that Loki Pruden himself
right so that Loki I think that's how the time
messiness happens with him getting yeah because
unfortunately there is one trailer shot that I
remember that we still that's what caused Loki to
be time displaced yeah is him zonking himself oh
so we're back we're literally back to now Ground
Zero Boris and but time itself imploding man if
this leads to an actual cleansing of Canon and
timeline for Kang Dynasty and then Marvel can do
I've been saying from the beginning give Marvel
the DSX Macha to clean up any story lines that
didn't work and this episode could do that I mean
I don't know if they're going to do that man and
then Deadpool just goes out killing universes that
are unwanted not on purpose uh post credit scene
episode I mean we all thought that mult the end
of Loki season one would lead to a craziness of
I will stay optimised until Marvel closes their
doors let's but in terms of what this episode
did alone like I like just thinking about what
the episode did I this is one like I I feel like
I would have to process a little bit just because
of how how well done it is like they have just
brilliant debates all around right from Loki and
Sylvie discussion of the the power that they they
hold and what does the TVA ultimately represent
like this was a fight for power and choice and
what the consequences of that could be despite
your intentions you know like that's what was
happening with raona that's what was happening
with Doc that's what was happening Loki and
Sylvie Victor's whole character is about the
consequences of actions about your attention like
that's his whole ass character yeah I I loved the
it's a big cautionary tale his minutes got merked
Victor got merked yeah yeah Aoki caused himself
to be time distorted and displaced we still have
all the ominousness of when Mia sees himself on
a jet ski I did it just really stands out to me
that in episode three they said in case he died
you give this to Victor timely I still feel
like we are watching he who remains big plan
because the way they frame this show especially
when Justin Aaron direct there's constantly this
and I'm not saying he who remains is alive I'm
saying I think we are watching something else
unfold that was part of he who remains big plan
I think we're seeing a Kang watch over I think
it was an act of subterfuge of what he was doing
when he was saying that oh you I want you Loki and
syvia to run the TVA and you guys do whatever
you want I don't think that was the reality of
the situ why else would he be like if I die
give this the because it's the or Bo you got
to start everything over yeah and I think this
is a big part of and I I definitely think that
the shots where they pull back and they show
a lens of someone watching something on a TV
someone watching something pull out of another
time that's the voyerism you're describing but
I think it's a Kang being aware it's not him
literally watching TV like the Matrix but it's
him watching yeah thematically watching over
a thing that he has put in place exactly we'll
go into the Kang architect room next episode and
he'll be like this is the sixth version of the TV
hope weally so many times if we meet real Kang
next week I think we meet real Kang next week
I think we meet a powerful enough to survive ants
yeah and what will he have to say about that like
guy took my name it wasn't me God I hope I really
thought we were GNA watch like uh something with
Victor timley it's it is like I love that I didn't
trust him ever it's crazy joh the Major's trial
coming up soon so we're going to have to ignore
that for for right now uh but wait see how that
plays out but it is crazy how he's he's managed
to play three distinct different Kings and if you
count quantam Mania like 46 more distinct than
the last definitely felt unique and not like a
bunch of people watching football game totally
that councelor Kang scene suddenly becomes a
little bit more questionable to me now that when I
when I factor in what they're doing here they R to
something entirely different than What's Happening
Here I feel like Loki is much like uh W division
where it's like someone watched half of something
they needed to like this feels this feels like
the followup to Loki but does not feel like it
acknowledges quantum Mania at all and like Quantum
Mania feels like it didn't acknowledge Loki at all
yes which could exist with multiple timelines and
if you destroy a bunch of them in this episode
Quantum man yeah I like ants look at the end of
Paul rud going like did that really happen maybe
not bro carry on to the next Avengers but don't
acknowledge that movie um back to the episode
the the the whole thing with Rona Ren Slayer I
I I feel like Rising um up in like realizing
what she really was before it is cool to see
I I wanted to see more of that side of her because
ravona and depending on what like the only thing I
really read was the one thing you recommended that
that brilliant King comic where where Nathaniel
Richards does learn about himself he Meed by he's
greeted by a king and written by Jackson and he's
like I got to stop myself from becoming this and
that he ends up just becoming himself the act of
trying to stop it is what causes it it is an Ora
Boris and I thought that like maybe that's what
was happening with Victor timley saying of oh is
is he accidentally going to become himself by like
trying to prevent himself from becoming especially
that Miss Mes line when Miss Mes is like it's what
you want or like you won't get it you want be
him there it is yeah yeah um and and then but but
raona is very much featured in that and they do
hint at that with he who remains like he did have
this sorrowful regret when he says I'm sorry when
he's by himself after uh you know giving the order
to wipe everyone's memory he says I'm sorry in a
way that does seem like sorrowful about it like
he had to make a hard Choice there and I I don't
know if they're implying that they're lovers you
know because like it traditionally it's there's a
there's a romance there there's a love but maybe
not that King cuz he who remains was definitely
more of an isolated character than a lot of kings
and then there's like other ronas throughout time
that it can be very much like Fierce Warriors and
we're going to meet one cuz she just got pruned
and I want to I want to see that version I mean
but if you've been pruned you're you're you're put
into the void and if you're put into the vo right
that's what happens you're putting where the void
at the end of time yeah yeah but I don't think she
oh she did come back from that once just now so
I guess it's possible yeah she got back because
of Mis minutes right um but but miss minutes when
she reboots might be able to bring it back again
perhaps uh so yeah I mean I feel like she'd be
going to the end of time and that's probably
where that Loki is right and they would and maybe
I mean my theory is that Arlo that Loki who got
pruned might be able to because because in that
last EP in last season they had to enchant elath
to distract right right that's what they did which
one's elith the Big Smoke monster smoke monster
yeah they had to enchant elath and I think but he
had to team up with Sylvie to do that yes and and
so maybe but that was wasn't strong enough no no
no they did do it because then they had um Richard
E Grant distracting with uh creating the asard
yeah so anyway I I don't know what I don't know
what they're going to do but that Loki still has
to exist right because there is one trailer shot
that everyone was screenshotting had I want to I
don't want to remind remember remember enjoying
things for the internet but that's the only other
shot I can think of that we haven't seen that we
haven't seen yeah that's the only other shot
I can think of there's nothing else that comes
to mind like we haven't seen this we haven't seen
this that that was the only shot I'm like oh yeah
there is one specific shot we haven't seen yet um
and it's like there's no way they would kill all
these people off so that's why I'm thinking maybe
they weren't killed yeah that they were actually
displaced somewhere else I wonder what the rules
are of the little jail box thing in that regard
then yeah I think they're smushed I mean it seemed
like there was residue there seems like there I
think jailbox people are dead I'm saying I'm
saying at the very end here like what happened
with all them yeah oh oh oh gotcha I think Loom
burst open I mean the it it's a very like this is
maybe the biggest Cliffhanger episode in Marvel
TV right cuz like that that could literally go
was well not not for a finale episode like for for
episode four and like for a singular episode like
this feels like a huge gap anything come episode 5
I don't know let's not forget before he was Ralph
boner he was quick oh touche for those beautiful
10 cents that's fair that might be the biggest
Cliffhanger between that are not a finale that was
bananas all right in recent memory this is quite
second to Ralph boner right right after boner
in entrance uh I loved how they manipulated our
expectations throughout that episode I really love
that I didn't trust Victor and I should have this
is really well crafted though like I I think
from a directing standpoint a cinematography
standpoint the way they clue Us in through what
these characters are experiencing through their
emotionality via lighting choices when to go
handheld how to make objects and items like feel
Larger than Life and have this sense of wonder
and fate yet with this Ting of like Darren arosi
fantasy sci-fi qualities to it where it does
feel dark wondrous but also kind of menacing
underneath and too there's a lot of wow with
like the mirrors and and the camera tilts and
PS there's also a really interesting element of
like the philosophy of like what extends beyond
the trolley problem like what's the trolley
problem for gods and you've got Gods discussing
the elements of the trolley problem but what's the
scope of like Mortals to Immortals you know what I
mean like what's a king to a god it's a God I I
feel like nicely done I I feel like I feel like
mob is I feel like everyone probably got back I
feel like a big reset happened for everyone at
that TVA and a lot whoever was still alive and I
think Mobius has probably planted back to who he
was interesting that's what I think happened okay
I think we're going to see some really fun because
they keep talking about that yeah no but I think
next episode is definitely some mobious timeline
stuff and I think it opens under jet ski and I
think we're going to be relying on and I I feel
like the opening shot of next episode is going
to be that one trailer you sh I'm talking about
I don't I I honestly think the opening of the next
week is going to be Mobius hun I don't remember it
now after thisis saw the trailer I think the
one time I I no I'm not I'm not even kidding
Marvel loves to do big Climax and then jump cut to
something you don't expect very specific shot damn
F I won't I won't remind you guys about it I won't
tell you but damn I do you you guys must know what
I'm talking about especially with the [__] you
guys are mentioning right now I I really feel like
like I know what the the the opening shot of next
one's going to be Loki at the End of Time Loki in
the void no I I I want I don't know jet ski sounds
like that's it sounds like a here what's fun about
this is whatever the opening shot could be is
next week I could just be like that was it yeah
I be like called could be like called it because
I didn't actually say the trailer shot no that
was the trailer shot cesal like I knew was the
cel feel I knew Thanos was coming back by the
way man this was great also I love that 20 minutes
in I was like this reminds me of the first episode
and that's how good they are as directors Aaron
and Justin are so good that like it was so their
style but I didn't assume it was theirs because
they just have this tone and Pace they it was a
great you call that right away that Loki pruned
himself yeah I called episode one and then I love
that they came back great job on the misleading
of shots to make it look like Sy might just right
yeah also love that the Ora Boris of the the
season they let Justin Aaron direct both ends
of the snake eating its tail I love that they
let the style reflect the director's take I I
do th think that there's that he who remains
there's something very like there's something
about Ora Boris the character not the not what it
means the concept of the character of obie because
there were similarities between him and he who
remains of characters who are isolated waiting
for visitors and the first visitor they get in
hundreds of years is Loki oh and they have all
this knowledge and this passing of information
that's why I was like will Ora Boris recognize
Victor timley in some capacity but he also didn't
seem to have his memory wiped entirely like I I I
don't know there was like something there like cuz
he was remembering [__] about uh Mobius and when
they had an encounter in that first episode
so he's beyond the wipe he's above it but the
end of Ant-Man implied the Nexus level being that
means all Kings look alike so I don't think he's
a Kang but what if he's a construct like Miss
minutes that he is something removed from time
so he's the aaor he's the self-reflecting art of
Kang's concept I mean why would you name him oror
like his name is Ora Boris it's a little on the
note you can't spell robot without OB like that
is not just some name GI you know what I mean you
know what I mean though well yeah they talking to
each other is the like something someone had to
have named him that unless when kangh hermain SL
timely knew all these events would occur they
knew he was the center of the aoris and thus
named him that because he's the one that has to
help them get time solved so he's the center of
this cycle a plant a robot an OB he's got to be
yeah he's the center the snake the loop I think
or he's I don't and I know they say Tom Works
differently in the TVA but he seems like he's
been around board for like hundreds of years
400 or whatever they said yeah yeah oh yeah
living but and I know time works differently the
TVA but I think he I think he's something made
that's what I'm saying saying yeah yeah I think
we're saying the same thing just using different
examples I feel like it's a he who I feel like
he who remains ma him yeah I think he's a Mis
minutes I mean we know he he can make convincing
animatronics yeah and what's more narcissistic
than a guy that wants to conquer time itself than
by making something that would be the thing that
solves it like heires him greatly like the
mirror to him right like let me bounce my
ideas off you off this mirror of my own creation
who loves me and then he's Herby and Fantastic 4
confirmed Easter eggs I'm so excited by this
show again yeah no I mean it's it's fun to be
left in a place where you're like breathless
and like Overjoyed but also like no not two
more it's only two more episodes and I'm going
to have to wait another like three years for
This Feeling Again however long it takes them
to do more Loki I do wish we had a little bit
more time with docs and all them that's the one
that's the one part of the show that I was like
o that would have hit a lot lot more and that
choice would have been more felt agreed I'm
like but you really didn't really SP if Episode
Two was seven minutes longer like episode two
feeling rush really has affected a lot I feel
like that is something that was significantly
paired for this because I think there's a lot of
interesting stuff you could do and they represent
an interesting side of the conversation about
all of this in terms of certain people learn the
truth and are immediately like oh my god what
have I done but other people take a long time
to deprogram or you know to build the trust to
see past the you know paradigms blah blah blah
and like I appreciated more in this episode that
they went swiftly about it because that created
a lot of unexpected situations and a lot of great
things to respond to in isolation I think the the
uh brevity of it here and the directness of it
here was good but at the same time uh especially
in light of episode two I think yeah you could
have expected that's why I'm saying putting it
there what allowed the weight to be here I think
this episode is perfectly paced but if that had
been earlier or we yeah checked in a little more
the past couple I feel like I've been bringing
this up every episode since episode two as much as
I love this one I put it up there with episode one
for me I put it up there with episode one oh uh
oh I still feel like like I I love watching Tom
uh Tom Heston because he's Tom Heston sure he
is still just kind of straightforward dramatic
resigned intense staring guy and I like I get
the ark I want an arc I wanted I want the ark
to stay through I'm not asking for to go back
to being like God of just be mischievous you
know but it is just kind of a straightforward
dramatic performance now and and I'm missing
some personality layers of the things that made
me fall in that make all of us fall in love with
Loki this does feel he is like essentially just
a a really really good TVA agent now I am missing
I am missing that like I appreciate the arcs and
the lines and the dialogue I appreciate all that
I shot so much emotion I could have two feelings
about it like I could appreciate a lot but I'm
like but I also feel like we're missing a lot
of we're missing this complete other layer of
the thing that got us on board with Loki to begin
with respect The Duality it feels like Ahsoka in
only in so far as this is much more an ensemble
than it feels like it's about its Title Character
not just that it's just a very straightforward
like dramatic character now you know what I mean
he's not as imp yeah he's not as like rascally
or there's no fun with Loki he's cly yeah he's
certainly not the god of Myster well I think
it's not he's there's no it's not a there's
no fun with him well cuz he's not at odds anymore
with like the bottom line of what's happening but
I love the intensity that's the thing I love the
intensity at the same time I'm like it's like with
Mobius they still manag to be have intensity
but also keep that level of fun you know it'
be fun but impossible to do because everybody
needs the namesake of Loki imagine if this show
show was called Kang and it was a Kang TVA agent
trying to stop himself from becoming Kang so you
replace the Tom Heston part with another Jonathan
major and it's Jonathan major as a TV agent more
Jonathan but imagine if if Jonathan major was
playing a straight La TV agent that is a Kang
variant that was trying to stop himself from
becoming Kang so he's trying to stock Victor
timley and he who remains from ever becoming the
Ora Boris that is Kang and then dealing with ob
so all that intensity would like build out both
characters but now I'm kind of questioning what
I said because I'm like it would make sense that
he's a little bit more dramatically resigned after
everything he's been through like like I mean
he has been significantly Changed by the things
he se he knows Tru so little of anything before
matters theie was being you got to get hope you
got to believe in something Heart Break of Sylvie
I mean what it does it doeses character-wise
line up my ridiculous idea just fixed Loki
for you you're welcome that's what it was
my thing that had nothing to do with here we
are me reflect on you're welcome IDE is so bad
that I like the show more it wasn't a bad idea
I'm just saying that it no I I think yeah no
no I I think both things can still be true it's
like I'm not upset because the placement of his
character and the emotionality of his character
tracks but you know that's like a quintessential
part of Loki that makes him distinct in the MCU
Pantheon as well as the comics Pantheon that he
is this mischievous figure and there's not as
much opportunity for misch I thought when he
was able to do magic with Brad yeah like that
kind of brought me closer to that place again
so part of me is like well you know the TVA
you can't use powers unless you shut off all
the security so like maybe if we could get back
out in the field there's like more opportunities
for that but at the same time I'm like clearly
like everything worth happening right now is at
the TVA so I cannot wait for next week yeah I'm
not even asking for to be like mischievous or or
devious in any way that's not even what I'm really
asking for it's just uh just more fun a little bit
more personality it's like there's a glimmer of
that old lowy charm in there I guess that's the
one simple way to put it like that some of that
old charm would be nice yeah totally totally some
charm a glimmer in his eye or something like that
because he is the most even mobus at times and
and I think they confronted that nicely in this
episode because he's so removed from everything
can have that whereas Loki is like so aware of
everything going on and his involvement and all
that that yeah I think he is burdened with
glorious Purpose with with glorious glorious
consequences all righty guys well what did you
think about this episode leave your thoughts
down below what would you rate it I would I would
give this like a solid I mean I like I loved it I
it's like a 10 out of 10 I loved it a lot yeah
I I was going 97 like I was big fan nothing's
perfect going 10.3 all right just just even even
a little better than perfect I know what I would
really remove from it man I thought that was like
one of the most that was like genuinely sus like
it was exciting and and rare as the day I say
with anything with Disney Plus shows especially
like that was actually not just a lot of times
it's like oh exciting intriguing I'm gripped
but I rarely say suspenseful and like that was
actually like this is this is intense this is
suspenseful [__] I don't know going to happen
and there were surprises that just kept happening
like and and and it wasn't like [__] Easter egg
surprises you know it was it it it was serious
and it ended in a way like I you just don't expect
yeah um and I I thought that was actually actually
suspenseful and I I I don't think I've said
that for any of the Disney Plus show episodes
not even not even lowy episode one season one um
I don't I don't even think I said it for season
one it's got tension it's got suspense in it and
it beautifully uses the disconcertion of all the
timey wiy strangeness like it it has that eeriness
that only this kind of sci-fi can bring you that
then like when you have those moments that's like
you know Rafa going down the hall or whatever like
those read as more traditional horror but yeah
there's just this there's yeah that 70s paranoia
they're all those like subtle stretch and Crush
zooms that they do like there's so much they do
to to just make you feel like everything is off
somehow and I think that is beautifully rendered
here and also accentuates every single other
emotional flavor they go for Loki's back on
top my number one MCU show again hundo PE I'm
just hoping it sticks the 6th all right guys
well thank you so much for being here and uh us
with a patron of the day shout out all right got
play some catch up on shout outs so we're going to
do this old old school old school meaning recent
Edition where we see how good chat gbt is oh sure
we're going to have real fun with this one we're
going to do F Doran and Ricardo Martinez is all
right where's my prompt where's my prompt chat
gbt I have a YouTube channel where I'm going to
shout our patrons are super sexy Rejects and then
there are Ricardo Martinez and fev Doran oh yeah
I want you to write a scene only do the dialogue
of them um surviving a like a zombie surviving
The Purge oh The Purge is even better yep that's
topical all right so let me give you some facts
about them let me give you some facts all right
John what do you know about flev fev uh he's
uh I think he lives in Romania dope uh he's
a a big uh like Marvel stuff fan lives in Romania
huge into marvelmcu he loves psych loves psych um
flev is a he's he's really ch chipper he's got
like a really positive energy chipper positive
energy okay what do you imagine his favorite
food is uh I imagine fev loves uh noi GN o
ccii sure what do you think you'd be hot
dogs then what do you think you'd be for
Halloween I think fev would be doctor strange for
Halloween would be doctor strange during The Purge
yeah totally in what would he be doing during
The Purge what would be his crime uh oh fev dur
The Purge would be he would be pirating movies
be pirating M movies constantly pirating movies
to last him to last him all 12 hours last him
last him the rest of the year yeah get a whole
library in that 12h hour window yeah totally um
okay and uh does he have a girlfriend boyfriend
he's got one of each he's got a girlfriend and
a boyfriend and uh they don't know about each
other he's worried they'll find out on Purge
night that's not gonna well but it's legal on
Purge Night uh yeah okay and uh how old do you
think he is I think flev is 27 27 years old and
uh he he got a sixpack yes he does okay it works
out a lot okay Ricardo Martinez okay Latino he's
Latino good was in served in the military oh
thank you veteran Loves movies all right okay
all right I know what do you think Ricardo
loves to e probably burritos loves burritos
tacos enchiladas ch he loves sourkraut he
loves BR worst he loves Bor um and uh what
kind of a car do you think he has oh he drives
a Geo drives a Geo and um what do you think his
favorite what do you think he'd be doing on Purge
Knight um he would be stealing a a different Geo
he'd be stealing a different Geo and um How
many um I mean do you think he has any STDs
at least a few has a few STDs yeah gu he's got
get to talk about it yes yeah definitely uh he
he he doesn't see a doctor about any things he
doesn't believe in in medical science to see a
doctor doesn't believe in medical science he's a
big conspiracy theorist huge conspiracy theorist
um uh very anti- pirating movies where he draws
the line and um yeah and then uh what's another
fun fact we can think about him what what do
we Muse about this guy um I think that loves to
stretch and yeah sure and he's always got a rose
clutched in his teeth always has a rose clutched
in his teeth and he can't bench very much even
though he's he looks fit he'll drive 30 miles
away in order to release a fart gotta yeah got to
have your Solitude the one thing he's embarrassed
about oh no um and uh owes a lot of money to
um his mom and and oh what's he dressed as for
Halloween and on Purge night he's dressed as uh
as a the Johnny Depp Madhatter as as Johnny de
mad at okay write me a scene only dialogue of them
encountering each other of them doing Purge night
together where a huge conflict arises between them
halfway through the scene between between them in
the middle of scene that may be the destruction
of their friendship oh Drama Oh this is going to
be heavy doc all right let's see what goes
down here let's see what's going on people
it's not letting me scroll okay here we go it's
just building suspense exterior purged Knight
abandoned alley night street lights flicker and
the distant sounds of chaos reverberate through
the valley the alley somewhere close we hear
the sounds of a GEOS engine Pur we got to do
this racist style John okay am I flever whose
race am I obscuring all right uh Ricardo this
is nuts never thought I'd see the day where
we'd be teaming up for The Purge and you as
mad hat that are bold Choice Ricardo with a
rose clut his to smirking Johnny Dey my friend
you know you as Doctor Strange is pretty ironic
especially given what you're planning tonight man
everybody has their advice a few pirated movies
won't hurt anyone besides I need enough movies
to last me the year F I might be anti-ed science
and a conspiracy theorist but piry movies that's
crossing the line I say come on Ricardo it's the
purge and hey didn't you just Hotwire that goo
I owe a lot of money especially to my mom's
need to save every penny but pirating that's
someone's hard work man look I understand that
and honestly I didn't want to bring this up but
you're constantly talking about your STDs and yet
you won't see a doctor that's someone's Health
we're talking about hey it's my choice least I
don't keep secrets about having a girlfriend and
a boyfriend what's going to happen if they find
out tonight man that's personal Ricardo how did
you even find out he my ways you're not the only
one with tricks up his sleeve I say I know I need
to sort it out I just can't bear the thought of
losing either of them and I can't bear the thought
of you stealing artist's hard work plus I must
I might love jles and burritos but I have found
youone you heathens out there enjoying your TR so
what now we go our separate ways tonight look live
I cherish our friendship but this this might be
the breaking point suddenly the distant Roar of an
approaching gang interrupts their confrontation we
need to move now agreed let's survive toight and
deal with our issues tomorrow the two make a hasty
Retreat their res unresolved conflict looming over
them as they navigate the deadly night to together
oh my God was brilliant that was yeah man I think
every script should be written by if you want good
comedy Chad GPT is unbeatable is just terrific
stuff favorite line is I might love churos and
burritos but I have values yeah you can't have
values if you're churro and burrito eater that's
just the Heathen food right there oh it's my
favorite I just yeah I I I really wish I
could ask the machine what it was thinking
about when it wrote that line let's
ask it what do you mean by I might
love churos and burritos but I have
values but I have values that sounds
like people who generally love churros
and burritos usually have a low moral
standard I apologize for that oversight
the intention was to contrast the lighter
humorous aspects of Ricardo's character with
a more serious stance on movie piracy but
the phrasing was off it was not meant to imply
anything negative about people who enjoy churos
burritos let me rephrase it leave rephrase
it to look I might have my quirks but I stand
firm on something piracy is where I draw the line
you're right Chad gbt this rewrite is just not as
funny yeah yeah sometimes you know you got to
smear a community of uh you know food enjoyers
to get the comedy okay I understand finding
the right balance between humor and clear
communication can be a challenge if you have
any other specific directions or ideas for
the scene I'm here to help otherwise thank you
for the feedback and I'm glad to assist further
in any way can it end with Ricardo leaving the
scene to go fart but he doesn't want to specify
that absolutely all right let's see let's
see what they do all right let's pick it up
from the end F we need to move now agreed let's
survive tonight and deal with our issues tomorrow
as they prepare to navigate the dangerous Street
chardo suddenly looks uncomfortable F I need to
um take a quick detour you know like P personal
reasons just give me like give like 30 minutes
30 miles 30 30 30 miles really now yes now
it's Sur surgent with that Ricardo hastily
rushes off leaving fev chucking chuckling to
himself as he imagines the true reason for
Ricardo's Hasty much better ending yeah yeah
that's true Easter yeah that was quality all
well we did it we did it guys thanks guys
we love you both dearly stay safe on Purge
Night